At MIT in the early 1980s, a bright
young iconoclast named Danny Hillis was
trying to build a new super computer.
He called it a connection machine.
It looked something like this.
You can tell it's a super computer
because its covered in blinky lights.
Fun fact about these lights, they would
actually blink according to where
communication was
happening in the system.
I don't know why we don't make
computers anymore with blinking lights.
We really should.
Anyway Hillis's PhD dissertation on
the connection machine is one of my
all time favorites.
In fact it even won
the doctoral dissertation award
from the association of
computing machinery in 1985.
That's one of the highest
honors a CSPHD can receive.
Now the kicker is that it won this
award despite its concluding chapter.
New computer architectures and
their relationship to physics or
why computer science is no good.
[NOISE] That's right,
but the best CS PhD of
1985 poo-pooed the entire discipline.
Now, Hillis was critiquing parallel
algorithms research of the time.
He argued that,
at the end of the day, an algorithm
has to run on a physical machine which
has to obey the laws of physics.
Yet algorithms researchers were,
in his opinion,
abstracting away way too many details
about the physical costs of computation.
Now Hillis was worried
about the speed of light
which fundamentally limits how
fast information can travel.
But today you could easily imagine
the melting butter experiment
as a physical cost
that we largely ignore.
But should we?
The answer Answer is a resounding,
I don't know, but
I do think Hillis might
have been on to something.
So what I want to do in this lesson is
to start from this line of thinking and
ask what would it mean to consider
physical costs in designing
an algorithm?